hey Bridget Willard here with you too
can be a guru you asked for more
questions here's one you're going on
vacation so you'll be gone for let's say
just for this scenario more than three
days and the question is do you schedule
your tweets and respond when you get
back from vacation do you schedule your
tweets and then respond as you're on
vacation or did you just not tweet at
all remember you too can be a guru
thanks Gary you're welcome
I think it's number four you tweet and
you respond because that's what I did
she's on vacation for two weeks first of
all you never schedule I'm gonna say it
again never in your life schedule a
tweet here's why you're on vacation for
three days you schedule a tweet of like
hey what's your favorite book and at
that exact moment we have the next
national tragedy happen at that second I
had multiple friends scheduled tweets
touring the Boston Massacre so here's
the Boston Massacre it's a terrorist
event on US soil the whole world shuts
down right and and my friends are
tweeting like you should buy my new book
it was yeah it was disgusting at best
and it was just it's devastating it just
it's and then and that's the extreme
what about like a lightweight version
like you schedule a tweet and right at
that moment on Twitter
the Cowboys score an important touchdown
and the Governor of New Jersey is
bouncing around and hugging Jerry Jones
and that's all that anybody wants to
talk about and you're a Cowboys fan or
from New Jersey and you're tweeting
about like what's your favorite book
and it makes you seem out of touch
there's no value in scheduling a tweet
I've never done it I don't believe in it
I will never believe in it period now
you're more than welcome
like I have on half my vacations to
check out completely and I highly
recommend that I was so excited about
doing that I told you that's what I
would do but unfortunately or
fortunately I caught the wine library
bug
and I enjoyed myself talking about wine
constantly on my vacation when Xander
and we shall were in the kids club and
doing their thing there or you know
while Lizzy was getting ready for the
dinner or finding my pockets going my
way so I think that um it's a personal
thing but boy do I hate do I hate
scheduling a tweet like don't do it
please don't do it
push oh crap wait subscribe do I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social so subscribe